uh okay next i want to talk about um
oh man i don't even know how to start
this so last week i interviewed andrew
yang a former democratic presidential
candidate former um new york city
mayoral candidate
during that
conversation one of the topics i brought
up was
who from the right
do you imagine would want to be part of
your third party movement and do you
welcome everybody from the right
and he answered the question and then
when he said everybody's welcome i
followed up and i said okay well what
about like real extremists like white
supremacists and he gave me an answer
and i believe that he sort of botched
the answer and as a result this has led
to absolute chaos
including andrew yang tweeting
about of course i don't support white
supremacy and this is a manufactured
controversy now it's not clear from his
tweet whether he's attacking me or
people reacting to what he said to me
but i'm gonna play the full section of
the interview for context you will see
that i was totally genuine in my
question
it was not an attack it was not a
manufactured controversy it was not a
gotcha it was just me following up
to what his answer was to my first
question so let's take a look at the
original clip from last week's interview
who exactly that currently considers
themselves to be on the right
does andrew yang imagine bringing into
the forward party and to kind of
make it a little more specific you know
we would imagine that there's lots of
progressive democrats
more centrist democrats even some folks
who really consider themselves centrist
maybe in the kind of line of even like a
john mccain who like the idea of some of
the reforms you're talking about and
that all kind of makes sense to me
when i think about people who believe
donald trump won the election
vaccines
the covet vaccine magnetizes you causes
autism whatever the case may be
etc right you know the package of ideas
that i'm talking about
one are are those people that would even
conceivably say this forward party idea
that andrew yang proposes in a coalition
with the left makes sense and number two
are these even people that you want as
part of your coalition
first let me say i want everyone as part
of the coalition you know if you can
vote we can disagree on a lot of things
uh it's all to the good if we agree on
the fact that this duopoly is uh not
working it's designed to turn us against
each other and sync us so that that's
one of the principles of the ford party
is that look i can disagree with you on
a lot of stuff but if we can make common
cause on this then we can go back to
disagreeing when the democracy is
actually set up to succeed when they're
you know
so let me i mean let me ask so even i
mean to to make it really specific
if people on the right say the
republican party is too centrist i'm an
extreme
white supremacist or something like that
but i think we need to get you know we
need single transferable vote or
whatever and campaign you you you still
welcome that because you're on the same
page on that one issue
yeah if they're going to help us
transition to a more effective democracy
um but you know i don't need to know
what their stance is on things that i
disagree with people have a sense of
where i'm coming from okay
but right now i believe that there is
an existential threat to the country
um as a result of the greatest design
flaw in the history of the world okay
so
his answer which i don't think was a
great answer
um
created a buzz
and a lot of people saying wow andrew
yang welcomes white supremacy some
people taking it out of context some
people just saying wow that wasn't a
really great answer so andrew yang
ultimately took to twitter a few days
after the interview
where he wrote quote i didn't think this
needed stating but people who hold
ideologies such as white supremacy that
are antithetical to grace and tolerance
are not welcome in the forward party our
movement for democracy reform is
fighting to diminish harmful extremism
now remember
in the interview with me he said that it
would be fine that they would be welcome
as long as they're okay with rank choice
voting that's what he said i didn't
trick him into saying that he followed
up with another tweet
which said quote relatedly this kind of
manufactured controversy is the kind of
thing that's dragging down our public
discourse and distracting us from the
true issues at hand he gave a bad answer
racist is not the path to enlightenment
now i didn't know whether he was
accusing me of manufactured controversy
or others on twitter of manufactured
controversy but in response to this i
tweeted
assuming this tweet is a response to the
question i asked during our interview i
hope it needs no clarification that i
was not attempting to manufacture
controversy and ask the question
completely genuinely after reading the
book now after the interview andrew and
i spoke off air for a bit
and he said
your question about white supremacy it
actually got me thinking and he said he
hadn't considered it he came up with the
answer you see him pause when he answers
the question he didn't say it was unfair
or a gotcha or manufactured controversy
we had a perfectly nice conversation so
i hope and am leaning towards
he was talking about people on twitter
weaponizing his answer now that being
said
i think he just did not answer the
question that well
if i were him the way i would have
answered that question would have been
to say david listen
i've denounced white supremacy
uh many times during the last few years
um
it's hard to imagine too many white
supremacists wanting to join a movement
led by an asian guy
but i can't control to whom these
principles appeal
and just like any candidate might end up
with anybody supporting them
i can't control that but
am i inviting white supremacist of
course not do i think white supremacist
will even be interested in this movement
of course not that's how i would have
answered the question he answered it a
different way which was to say yeah if
they want ranked choice voting then
they're welcome
so
um what is this ultimately really about
for me it's about
who exactly from the right are we
looking to pull in to this forward party
and we had a good conversation about
that um and i don't know that
necessarily more has to be said but i'd
be curious to your reaction to the
entire exchange